again from capital one arena russ thanks
for taking a couple of minutes with us
uh hey always a good sign when your lead
is so big that you can throw your shoes
to the crowd with about four and a half
minutes to go huh
it's the best feeling i mean i ain't did
it in a while so i looked i
enjoyed that tonight hey look when uh
when you look at your season at one
point you were 17 and 32
and then you go 17 and six and you and
you work your way
into this tournament now into the
playoffs what did that tell you about
what this team is made of um resiliency
man we we got a lot of guys in the
locker room
we've been through so much covet um
injuries but we stuck with it you know
we had a
time in our season where we could have
quit but the guys in the locker room
didn't do it
uh did an amazing job of sticking with
each other sticking to what we do and
what we know and uh we put ourselves in
position to be in the playoffs
russ shack here i said before the game
great players never have two bad games
in the world
you didn't play russell westbrook style
the first game for whatever reason
happened to the best of us
what was your mentality going into this
game too um
attack in boston i was terrible
i let my teammates down and i knew it
and coming in tonight i wanted to set
the tone
all aspects of the game is what i do
defending rebounding passing
um that's going to basketball tonight i
did that
for us between covet injuries
and things like that you guys have you
know
not just you guys the whole nba yeah you
guys are finally
quote unquote healthy so you think we've
seen the best
version of the wizards um i think we
just we kind of getting
getting started we still got some guys
out you know i mean tv denny we still
got some guys out but
uh we got some tough guys in the locker
room that i believe in with everything
that we have and um hopefully we can
shock the world
take one game at a time get ready for
philly and go take care of business
you know rush first congratulations on
the unbelievable feat with the
with the triple doubles i mean a feat
that none of us thought could ever be
broken first congratulations there
thank you but i had a candid i had a
conversation over the weekend with
michael jordan
and we were debating what's the hardest
part
of getting the triple-double for russell
westbrook
what would be the hardest part of
getting the uh triple-double
um the hardest part is probably what you
can't control is to assist
i can't control that's what he's saying
i can't control if guys make shots
but i can make it easy for them but i
can't control if they scored or not but
i can
i can rebound on my own i can score my
own but i can't control if guys make
shots or not
i would have said rebounding oh my gosh
okay go ahead chuck
hey russ you got time for one more from
chuck yes yeah hey russ
uh i just want you to know on the fan
duel game tonight me and kenny both said
you're gonna have a triple-double i just
want to thank you for letting us down
i'm sorry my bad uh i'll be better next
game you know
hopefully i can do my job i'm not bad
[Laughter]
rush you got time for five more from
shaq absolutely go ahead
hey we appreciate you man
congratulations ross thank you see you
in the playoffs